so we have two complex numbers here the
complex number Z is equal to 2 plus 3i
and the complex number W is equal to
negative 5 minus I what I want to do in
this video is to first plot these two
complex numbers on the complex plane and
then think about what their distance is
between these two numbers on the plane
and what complex number is exactly
halfway between these two numbers or
another way of thinking about it
what complex number is the midpoint
between these two numbers so I encourage
you to pause this video and think about
it on your own before I work through it
so let's first try to plot these on the
complex plane so let me draw so right
over here let me draw our imaginary axis
so our imaginary axis and over here let
me draw our real axis real axis right
over there and let's first let's see
we're going to have go as high as
positive 2 and the real axis and as low
as negative 5 along the real axis let's
go 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 and along the
imaginary axis we go as high as positive
3 and as low as negative 1 so we could
do 1 2 3 and we could do 1 2 3 and of
course I could keep going up here just
to have nice markers there although we
won't use that part of the plane now
let's plot these two points so the real
part of Z is 2 and then we and then we
have 3 times I so the imaginary part is
3 so we would go right over here so this
is 2 and this is 3 right over here 2
plus 3i so that right over there is Z
now let's plot W W is negative 5 1 2 3 4
5 negative 5 minus I so this is negative
1 right over here so minus I that is W
so first we can think about the distance
between these two complex numbers the
distance on the complex plane so one way
of thinking about it that's really just
the
of this line right over here and to
figure that out we can really just think
about the Pythagorean theorem
when if you say hey what about the
distance formula and not icon in the in
two dimensions well that's really just
an application of the Pythagorean
theorem so let's think about that a
little bit so we could think about how
much have we changed along the real axis
which is this distance right over here
this is how much we've changed along the
real axis and if we're going from W to Z
we go it we're going from negative five
along the real axis to two what is two
minus negative five well it's seven if
we go five to get to to get to the zero
along the real axis and then we go two
more to get to two so the length of this
right over here seven and what is the
length of what is the length of this
side right over here well along the
imaginary axis we're going from negative
one to three so the distance there is
four so now we can apply the Pythagorean
theorem this is a right triangle
so the distance is going to be equal to
the distance let's just say that this is
X right over here x squared is going to
be equal to seven squared this is just
the Pythagorean theorem plus four
squared plus four squared or we could
say that X is equal to the square root
of 49 plus 16 I'll just write it out so
I don't skip any steps forty-nine plus
sixteen and what is that going to be
equal to that is 65 so X that's right
yeah fifty-nine plus another six is 65 X
is equal to the square root of
sixty-five and let's see 65 you can't
factor this you there's no factors that
are perfect squares here this is just 13
times five so we can just leave it like
that X is equal to the square root of 65
so the distance in the complex plane
between these two complex numbers square
root of 65 which as I guess a little bit
over eight now what about the complex
number that is exactly halfway between
these two
well to figure that out we just have to
figure out what number has a real part
that is halfway between these two real
parts and what number has an imaginary
part that's halfway between these two
imaginary parts so if we had some let's
say that are some complex number let's
just call it a is the midpoint its real
part is going to be the mean of these
two numbers so it's going to be two plus
negative five two plus negative five
over two over two and it's imaginary
part is going to be the mean of these
two numbers so plus plus three minus 1 3
minus one minus one over two times I and
this is equal to let's see 2 plus
negative five is negative three so this
is negative three halves plus this is
three minus one is negative is negative
two over two is so let's see three
mining make sure I'm doing this right
three so I'm taking the mean three minus
one is two divided by two is one so
three plus three negative three halves
plus I is the midpoint between those two
and if we plot it we can verify that
that actually makes sense so real part
negative three halves so that's negative
one negative one and a half so it'll be
right over there and then plus I so it's
going to be right over
there and obviously I didn't draw it
perfectly to scale but this makes sense
that this right over here would be the
midpoint